do you ever think about free will
and uh whether that exists because
ultimately free will sort of is this
experience that we have like we're
making choices
even though it appears that
you know the world is deterministic at
the core i mean
it's against the debate but if it is in
fact deterministic at the lowest
possible level
uh at the physics level
uh how do you make if if it is
deterministic how do you make uh
how do you make sense of the difference
between the experience of us
feeling like we're making a choice and
the whole thing being deterministic
so first of all let me give you a gut
reaction to my question
and we got reaction is that
it is important that we believe that
there exists free will
and second of all almost uh
by weird logic if we believe it exists
then it does exist
okay yeah so it's very important for our
social
apparatus for our sense of idea of
ourselves
that it exists and the moment in which
you know we
we so want to be almost we conjure it up
in existence
but again i really feel that if you look
at some point
and the space of free will seems to
shrink
we realize how more and more how much of
our
say genetic apparatus dictates who we
are why we prefer
certain things than others right and why
we react to noises of music
we will prefer poetry of everything else
we may explain even always
but uh but at the end of the day whether
it
exists in a philosophical sense or not
it's like randomness if you can
no pseudorandom is as good as random
vis-a-vis lifetime of the universe our
experience when does it really matter
you